it's election season at the United
Nations and Slovenian foreign minister
Tanya fayon has arrived to make her
country's case for a seat on its most
powerful body the security Council
Slovenia is in the running to represent
Eastern Europe we are a small country of
2 million people but we are very
ambitious we prove to through our
history that we are committed to the
respect of other countries that we are
working together with Partners like any
election this one involves campaigning
and debate but Slovenia was a relatively
last minute addition to the ballot
angering its competitor Belarus the
Republic of Belarus presented
its candidacy back in 2007.
Valentin rybikov accused Western powers
of pushing Slovenia to prevent an ally
of Russia from joining the council not
surprisingly Russia supports Belarus we
see no evaluated in another member of
the Western European group in the
security Council there are too many
already Yes we share values with EU at
the same time we have our own foreign
policy our own foreign minister
the Belarusian ambassador to the UN
shares an office in New York with
Russian and Ukrainian diplomats
as neighbors as friends as brothers and
sisters of both ukrainians and Russians
what do we need to do to make these
people these countries stop the war sit
down at the table and discuss this
rybackov claims other diplomats are also
tired of being strong-armed by the West
especially when it comes to the war in
Ukraine that's raising Global
instability and food prices but given
his own government's disputed elections
and record of repression human rights
groups say Belarus doesn't deserve the
seat countries have a chance to reject a
country that has proven itself to be a
Shameless cheerleader for Russian
atrocities in Ukraine plus it's got its
own human rights abuses at home the
security Council meets down the hall but
the election will take place right here
in the general assembly on June 6. it's
a secret ballot and to win will require
the support of two-thirds of all member
states Kristen salumi Al Jazeera the
United Nations
still ahead on Al Jazeera one of
Africa's